all right record everyone behave
politely Morgan watch the language
Ashley don't get too naughty I'll try
not to make any promise
[Music]
hello reject nation my name is the
Gregory album over here let's start to
the left the Ashley enter let's go to
the right B Morgan hand from how to's
and Morgan and actually I was really on
their channel very patriotic punch
we made some patriotic dreams yeah cuz
fourth of July is coming up so they were
teaching me how to get drunk in a
fashionable subway it was delicious
link in the description box to go watch
that video rather that's who I'm a riot
that one yeah yeah we're gonna watch the
trailer for a movie called the greatest
showmen stars a few people it might be a
musical Oh looking at the cast here Zac
Efron Roxy oh my gosh is that get you
excited I don't know for sure if it's a
nice door oh hello you back man my car's
named after Hugh Jackman just a fraud
great it looks like a Wolverine and my
call will ring home sorry Jackie
I'm a really dirty car
oh he'll my hat retention
you're all dismissed thankful their luck
with your next job shall William hmm
good call look like Harry Potter or
Manhattan now the production design on
this thing
in Russia in the NuStar Ringling
Brothers
everyone's like anyone Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
you
and aerial yoga
what happened there
[Music]
never made a difference by being like
everyone else I can't just run off and
delay the circuit
why not you clearly have a flair for
show business Shou Bou very interesting
done did not actually happen for really
no idea I don't know is he the guy who
invented the circus invented through
business but that'd be cool
featuring original song for the Academy
award-winning lyricist of la-la-land oh
gosh I just imagined alright here's the
description from I am too good inspired
by the imagination of PT Barnum the
greatest showman is an original musical
that celebrates the birth of show
business of show business man tells of a
visionary who rose from nothing to
create a spectacle that became a
worldwide sensation oh how we need how
did I become is not based on trees right
there was a well reeling brothers in
portable shared asserted survivors
essence pot inspired by a heap so is it
nobody was singing so it's not a musical
but there's a lot of dancing or it'll be
I imagine that when they're doing their
show like when they're performing the
characters are perfect but they're not
like speaking in the Maori yeah yeah I'm
Dan now yeah I imagine that the kind of
musical a bit probably doing is that
like oh you get musical numbers when
they're actually performing but it's not
exactly like a dialogue as musical I
feel that circus every year did you
really mmm I've never been to the circus
oh my gosh if you were going to go to
one at the circus you were going to go
to really you know circuses now I've
never seen freaks live with the Vegas
show and in current circus circus away
that one but also no no there's another
one when your Spears live oh no I'm sure
you can have a circus tour but breezers
it that's the circus I went to take a
few girls like a districts the language
Asli tricks no no acid does it that's
the one oh I'm robbing your nail that
one down lady
tell the old asleep tonight i hugh
jackman famously
retiring his famous wolverine logan
character
this is his follow-up film and i think
it's a good choice for him because
musicals is a lot more online what I
think his original passion for
filmmaking or acting really is yes
that's where he started right art early
musicals he's won Tony Awards when he
hosted the Oscars he's saying he was in
it it was like a lot to get through
well yeah the miserable no I mean I've
seen the play but like the movie the
movie are rough I'm not a huge fan of
movies where they're talked singing like
if there's numbers like this that's cool
or like you remember the movie nine with
like Fergie in Cape Cod style yeah I
liked that movie I liked because there's
like dance numbers but it like I you
know like this is cool - there's dancers
but I'm not a huge family just like her
speaking they break out into a song I'm
like without it dance real is more like
well I have many other things I feel
like you have to find a different
American accent because every time I
hear that American accent I usually go
to like hearing Wolverine every time I
hear him because he does a lot of
different roles but it was genuine for
an American it was different kind of
American accents you can do different
ways to find Michael I know maybe it's
just the one that heat specific agenda
British accent could you do different
British accent yeah different types of
British accent fancy one and then the
kind of like you know slang one Hugh
Jackman looks like he's doing a really
good job you should a dialect coach yeah
that's my problem Jackman favourite
people of all time maybe when it came
like Oscar consideration time yeah for
sure and it looks pretty like it's all
like a shot I mean this is immense Agra
peda production design looks fantastic
I really hope we do get to explore
because you know they were like really
showing an awful lot of their main cast
actor from
Ferguson or they're all fantastic actors
but when you're talking about the
surface I want to see more of that in
the trailer bearded lady
yes I want to see more of like circus
stuff like promote in front and center I
don't know if that might be like a
little off-putting to put in a trailer
that seems like it's for those marketing
towards families I don't know I feel
like that's the most appealing part of
the circus to me it's a weird stuff yeah
and I would like to see them enhance
more the Weir's up as a surface like a
musical thing you know it's a lot more
of just like there's music and fun and
they like tricks a lot of effects
there's not even a lot of talking really
and there's not a ringleader well the
last island to the circuit I think I
want to know everything brothers and run
on Bailey's two years ago and there
wasn't even like a ringleader anymore
it's kind of like you they walk around
and like wave it's not like no yeah was
there a bearded lady when you went to it
it was way more like like an old-school
it was way more acrobatic and tricks
India and lions and things as opposed to
like the odd stuff what started out at
me did you guys ever see The Prestige oh
yeah wait I get that in the illusion I
love you she they were in the stage and
I'm kind of thinking of the prestige a
little bit your product is the time
period yeah yeah yeah yeah I love that a
fraud I used to not I used but it was
when he started doing comedies when I
really liking him like my neighbors I
really loved him in now I'm wanna go see
anything that should be a lot of people
didn't see Baywatch I said I don't know
I think seeing Zac Efron Hugh Jackman
acting together was probably the most
intriguing part to me is actually very
talented and people forget that he can
do serious roles yeah Andy's a fantastic
singer too he's an amazing speed musical
dance artist - yeah that's ready start
off with High School Musical and he did
hairspray now another musical good for
you Zac Efron ease come along the
musical kings
how are you John Sunderland that's
actually good oh really you know we work
with him on Summerland huh videography
um we changed information and I know
that you did I really should have
yeah well you look like Lin and all you
look like now it would have been I in
and now it would have been like I really
should have pursued that part yeah yeah
you should have man you wouldn't have
here right now filming with us you do
what somewhere else is available I
definitely will see it it looks like you
want to see it in the theater you know
yeah I like your lighter line from
Anderson the theater when I feel like
the sounds to be good I need to be in a
good environment for them yeah of course
the cinematic a matter we have a date
movie date night yeah all three of us
and the guy who wrote this he wrote
Dreamgirls oh that was a road yeah he
wrote the 2017 version of Beauty and the
Beast and he collected it actually there
you go people involved in this to have
musical background experience I'd be
very surprised if this was any good
musical it's barely watching them
Braveheart going to turn out well yeah
and I like any story with the theme of
you know to be successful or to really
stand out or to make a difference you
got to be different
I just wanted he said it was I don't
remember it but it was pretty epic about
it no one's ever made no never agree
normal or something I don't know
whatever made a difference by being like
everyone else really well that seems
like the theme of the whole movie and
yeah I feel like a lot of times in life
we do try to just fit in and be normal
and I really like the approach of you
know being weird is the best way to do
it and that's why I was hoping we'd see
more weird stuff in the trailer
yeah for you know just everything
committee outward I'm latched on to the
main protagonist I like the idea of this
guy being a father who started from
being broken had Empire build them there
so nobody mentioned Michelle Williams to
humbly she was your wife
my favorite rapper they don't really
capitalize on the the females and she
has his trailer the Michelle Williams is
one of the best actresses I think we
have around right now and Rebecca
Ferguson is also a great actress
attitude so Rebecca Ferguson we see
Mission Impossible rogue nation can't
help me now amazing I'm going to be
Grothe of ones day actually shooting the
girl train girl the train for ecology
yeah I know she's in the girl the train
was she's a girl on
I know she was the she was the new wife
British action shot yeah Lee Jiwon and
Rebecca Ferguson yeah I do a different
version
well I can't remove all this don't worry
I'm all right yeah we're gonna do a how
to video this is right now there's my
fair lady British and there's you know
coffee yeah and then there's like the
Queen which is like the microwave a
smaller size it's merely the cat that's
why the biggest Ronnie Michelle Williams
zendaya zendaya Toys R Us you know your
son into the Disney Channel ah burger
star does it like her big like breakout
well she's the main female lead in the
new spider-man movie getting a really
real names and Dan are you miss yeah
like you're not going to have your
family please call me petunia subscribe
is a real reject this is like that
notification bell most importantly
though check out how to's the more
internationally on their youtube channel
follow them how to blog make a right on
instagram yeah there's so little
accounts as well I'm in a video with
them on one on their Channel you're on
Julia's Bush emotion ways and one you
guys don't know how to promote sorry
brutal the most recent one lady gotta
get drunk I don't even remember I
remember go follow them mmm patreon blah
blah blah